[Music]
let's talk about wanderlust uh the this
movie uh to set it up briefly you and
your husband who's played by paul rudd
you decide to
you have to move we have to move you
have to we're we basically cannot afford
he gets fired we have to move out of the
city to atlanta to stay with his
horrible horrible brother beautifully
played by ken marino and um we and on
our way we stop at what we think is a
bnb and it turns out to be this crazy
commune yes it's a commune and there's
there's it's very hippy-dippy-ish this
commune and it's insanity ensues well
there's an uh and there's a nudist
character in it and uh played by an
actor a very funny guy joe
joella trulio and um he is fully
frontally
nude nudist uh and it's yes uh and in
quite a shocking way jarring isn't it
quite jarring uh and then uh fascinating
uh but you're looking at it and i'm
thinking was that real or what's
happening there please yeah that's good
to know it's uh it is not real it's not
real no that you're not seeing his
actual male member no but you are seeing
other male members and and the nudists
that actually did were background people
and when you see that slow motion shot
where they're all running yes
yeah but joe no joe when you get used to
it it was within 10 minutes we were
having normal conversations and he was
getting touch-ups it was no it was
normal so there'd be uh special effects
people that would come in and work on
this
device that he has on him on his person
focus on the eyes focus on the eyes
focus on the eyes it was a hard mantra
to get because you'd want to you know it
can't help it's natural it's uh
yeah hi nice to meet you
this was it's set on a farm did you did
you shoot this in clarksville georgia
georgia heaven beautiful most beautiful
uh
countryside and we were there the most
gorgeous time of the year was just going
from fall to our summer to fall and so
we had some lake time and we were all
on this lake am i being rude to you by
just no not at all not at all okay it's
the it's the way it is
i'm sorry okay
just before and andy when we go out
there you not to speak to her
no it's just eavesdropping basically
exactly it's creepy it's pervy the way
he's doing it look
you go ahead and finish yeah
[Laughter]
there's a scene on the farm where you
milk a goat i do and it looks like you
really milked the goat i did really milk
a goat had you done that that was not
stunt milking yeah well it was horrible
uh i had not i've done it once at the at
the camera test and i couldn't do it
because it was seemed really too intense
right it was you'd really grab at it and
it was like i'm a city girl i'm not
that's not my thing right right so but
then i was like during the day i had to
get prepped and i just went for it and i
was like bite the bullet let's just milk
this thing right and it was did you make
you feel like okay i could live on a
flight you did it no no you don't ever
want to do that again no
i know i wouldn't be opposed to it right
but it wouldn't be like i'm gonna move
to a farm and milk goats
i'm shocked that you're not going to do
that are you does that make me a bad
person yes it does
yes it does we're very judgmental show
here
we have a clip here and i believe
this is a scene where you uh mistakenly
uh it's almost like you're tripping oh i
am tripping
yeah you are tripping no mistakes here i
forget what happens something you drink
something that's been sitting it's a t
where did we do a truth circle
and we have this great scene with the
whole cast and then we all end up having
a hallucinogenic
trip it's a very funny towards the end
it's a very funny scene the part where
there's a lot of special effects where
we're seeing what you're seeing but uh i
think this is uh the effects of you
taking this let's take a look at this
clip from wanderlust
i can fly i believe i can fly george
metaphorically i believe you can fly
literally you can't fly i believe i can
fly you know what if you're gonna get
literal with an r kelly song let's do
trapped in the closet you can't break
your neck if you're trapped in the
closet
just watch me no no no no watch me
george no no no no i believe i can go
solve
[Applause]
it you can't fly
i always believed
[Applause]